so after covering a couple of notable
anti-vaccine coveted deaths last week
many of you over the weekend sent me all
sorts of other examples of this and
there's a couple I want to highlight and
I highlight these not to point the
finger and laugh at people I don't find
that there's anything to laugh at but
just to show all of the different ways
in which this toxic delusional thinking
infects people
and then they end up in horrible
situations their families end up in
horrible situations and it's absolutely
horrifying an anti-vaccine podcaster who
got coveted at a conspiracy conference
during which coveted conspiracies were
spread has now died of covet I'm talking
about 61 year old Doug kuzma
a q Anon an anti-vaxx podcaster has died
from complications due to covid after
getting the virus at a conspiracy theory
conference which became a super spreader
event where attendees blamed their
illness on an Anthrax attack I don't
know if you remember that
last week or maybe maybe it was the week
before I told you about this conspiracy
conference where tons of people got
covered and they said we believe we were
targeted with Anthrax and of course you
apply a simple kind of colloquial
Occam's razor what's more likely that
Anthrax which is difficult to get in the
U.S really more prevalent in other parts
of the world and uh it is what's
responsible as a targeted attack against
us when the symptoms are the one of the
virus that's rapidly spreading
everywhere why would we choose the
anthrax over the code well didn't make
any sense this guy has now died not from
Anthrax but from covid Doug kuzma 61
year old from Newport News Virginia died
after being hospitalized 10 days earlier
kuzma broadcasted on the Frog news
podcasting Network which stands for
fully rely on God kuzma and His fellow
hosts pushed an array of conspiracy
theories ranging from Q Anon to covid
denial and election fraud lies
kuzma attended the reawaken America
conference in Dallas on the weekend of
December 11th posting a picture of his
media pass
other images posted show large crowds in
confined spaces with no social
distancing or masks I literally told you
guys when we would look at clips from
reawaken America these are covet
hellscapes and now he has died
the conspiracy-laid an event organized
by Tulsa businessman clay Clark was
headlined by people like the disgraced
former National Security adviser Michael
Flynn conspiracy theorist Alex Jones and
Eric Trump several unvaccinated
conspiracy theorists and fraud promoters
basically claimed they were targeted
with Anthrax kuzma reported he was
feeling ill claimed it was chronic
bronchitis flaring up again
from the picture he looks obese and
chronic bronchitis and you don't get a
vaccine and when covet is rampantly
spreading you go to a conference with
tons of other unvaccinated and unmasked
people
it's really unbelievable
some um on December 15th he posted that
he had a fever someone commented he
should get a covet test and he said no
way
he was told better safe than sorry and
he lashed out saying You must have lost
your mind so they can kill me and try to
give me the jab I'll die at the house
before I go to the hospital well after
suffering for fever for five days he was
forced to admit he probably had coveted
he was found unconscious at his house on
Christmas Eve and rushed to the hospital
uh he was not responding to treatment he
was sedated and placed on a ventilator
according to a fellow member the final
message kuzma sent was a photo of
himself
with a refill of ivermectin oh my God
um
his daughter stopped sharing posts about
his condition because she was against
his truther movement he pushed anti-vax
conspiracies they also provoke promote
multi-level marketing company life wave
on the Frog Network which sells wearable
patches that promise to activate your
stem cells and reset them to a younger
healthier state
um man you know it this is instructive
in so many ways
the MLM stuff he was pushing it didn't
help him survive the Ivermectin didn't
help him
uh he didn't get the vaccine and you
know Candace Owens recently said she'll
die before getting the vaccine that is
clearly that there are people choosing
that
there are people choosing that and this
is sad this is not something I look at
and I laugh at and we have another
example to look at
it is a brand new year maybe you have
goals around getting in better shape
maybe cutting back on sugar that's why
you should check out our long time
sponsor magic spoon magic spoon tastes
exactly like the delicious sweet
breakfast cereals you loved as a kid but
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar 14
grams of protein and only four net carbs
so it's perfect if you're doing low carb
or keto or if like me you just try to
limit your sugar intake you can build
your own variety pack with flavors like
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
cinnamon cookies and cream waffle Maple
blueberry that's my favorite magic spoon
lets you enjoy a sweet delicious snack
without the guilt you can stick to your
goals and still treat yourself and if
you don't love magic spoon as much as I
do they'll give you all of your money
back no questions asked magic spoon is
giving my audience five dollars off when
you go to mad spoon.com slash Pacman and
use the promo code Pacman